[Music]
machi
good morning ladies
good morning good morning sir trainer
of
[Music]
and the most pleasant thing about the midwives
and my colleagues
that they told me that I am strong
that I am brave and they said
positive words to me and also my
midwife  months my daughter told
me she said you can she told me and
they were always with me she supported me
so if I felt very safe
[Music] it
was a very very nice
experience giving louis in my own house it
was difficult
because as she was he collaborated a lot
so I didn't  it was difficult it was a
very beautiful experience
[Music] it
breathes
neighboring castles
because yes
[Music] it
is an emotion it is a joy to say that
my goddaughter
and to dream
old the conjectures
maybe and say my God thank you very much
because this birth went well the baby
It's fine, the afterbirth
came out, we're going to bury it in the temascal
because we are from the land and we
have to return to the land
[Music] We get
the family together and  we make a bit of
lunch
[Music] he
says that it helps give us strength,
so good
[Music]
we always always do
but our members in
section b
are minimal
[Music]
three years and what they  students are
with us they live in the school
because they have the full scholarship
life is the audio and channel is
first the announcement
with the philosophy of the heart of water is
that all people also have the
opportunity to make
conscious decisions to focus more too  to
a much healthier life empowered
also with knowledge of their rights
with knowledge of their options and that is
also in harmony with nature
so the plan now with the graduates
the guides return to their communities
start providing services and we are going to
start a kind  of a cooperative of
midwives in which, well, we are going to
be helping each other but with a
little blood if she has anemia
what to do  rda we can become unbalanced
and we can go into shock very quickly it
is a requirement for the scholarship to have a
midwife in the community with whom
they can also learn
from her ancestral knowledge but
who can also share with her the
knowledge they have acquired  at
school
and this guarantees us that the
community is seeing her grow little by
little from the beginning and
the student is also gaining more confidence
[Music]
I'm going to look for her here there is a clinic
where 16 midwives from
different communities attend
and I started to
practice with them and
as time goes by we are not relating
sharing experiences
[Music]
Erika was one of the
most attentive, most hard-working practitioners and she
had that, that is, how I do it
and she watched how I did it and then
he asked me why he did it and I
explained to him
and
[Music]
there are certain actions
what makes me happy is for example to
see the children are born  r being able to help the
women of the community because
it is how they should feed themselves to
see the years grow healthy
[Music]
care
not
what I could transfer
to women who have power
over them  of them that they are capable of
everything and that they decide on their body
because in the end the woman is is she is
her body is not other people's I
take this level
[Music]
because one thing is the best that's how
you get it
and one like that you love them  imbecile armchairs
and okay it
comes
[Music] she
has been my comadre since I began my
career we
buried
she taught me she said look, you only observe what I
do and when you feel safe you do it
[Music]
what I love being part of being with
the woman during  her life well her whole
life
guatemala is a country in which
well more or less around 50
percent of the population has their babies
at home
what we want is for women to
have access to a respected birth to a
birth that is  in your community that is
in your language
[Applause]
[Music]
Our goal is also to be able to
guarantee good care at home
to also be able to guarantee an
effective link with health establishments
to also be able to reduce the
risks
they teach us everything theoretical and a month  of
practice in our communities
taking practices with midwives in a
health center
l
and
at 7 at night
for years the attention
was very difficult to be able to share
the doctor the professional because they did not accept
the accompaniment of the midwives
[Music]
us  we know that culturally
they are very accepted it
has to be with force, cigars happen
because with force without force
[Music]
let's go we love each other very much she
had the cord around her neck and that prevented
the baby from coming
down thank god everything went well
and currently well the  ladies are
now being a practice and they were given
the opportunity to take turns
serving
they can make a change
is u  n link between the population
between the family and the
hospital service is fine
and
already
[Music]
[Applause]